Graph a line that
has a slope that
is negative and greater than
the slope of the blue line.
So let's think for a second
about what slope means.
So if you use the word
slope in your everyday life,
you're really talking about
how inclined something is,
like a ski slope.
So for example, this orange
line isn't inclined at all.
It's flat, so this one
actually has a slope of 0.
Another way of thinking
about it is as x increases,
what is happening to y?
And you see here that y
isn't changing at all,
so this orange line right
now has a slope of 0.
If the orange line
looked like this,
it now has a positive slope.
Notice, when x is
negative, your y
value-- or say when
x is negative 5,
your y value is here, and
then when x is positive 5,
your y value has increased.
As x increases, y is increasing,
so this has a positive slope.
This has an even more positive
slope, an even more positive
slope.
This has an even
more positive slope.
As x is increasing, the y value
is increasing really fast.
This line is going
up really fast
as we move towards the right,
so it's a very positive slope.
This is less positive,
less positive.
This is a 0 slope, and then
this is a negative slope.
Notice, as x is increasing,
the line is going down.
Your y value is decreasing.
When x is negative
5, your y is 7.
Well, when x is 5, your y is 5.
So x is increased,
but y has gone down,
so this is a negative slope.
So they say graph a line
that has a slope that
is negative and greater than
the slope of the blue line.
So the blue line also
has a negative slope.
As x is increasing, your
blue line is going down.
Over here, when x
has negative values,
your y value is quite high.
And here, when x
has positive values,
your y value has gone
all the way down.
So this has a
negative slope, but we
want to have a slope
greater than this one.
So we still want
to have a-- they
say graph a line that has
a slope that is negative--
so my orange line currently
has a negative slope--
and greater than the
slope of the blue line.
So it has a negative
slope, but it
is less negative than this
blue line right over here.
If I wanted to be more
negative than the blue line,
I'd have to do
something like that.
But I want to be negative
but less negative
than the blue line, so
that would be like that.
If we wanted a 0 slope, once
again, something like this.
If we wanted a positive
slope, something like this.
So once again, negative
slope, less negative
than the blue line.
Check our answer.